et tout de suite dans paris direct info
ou intox
info ou intox avec anthony st léger ce
soir anthony bonsoir
l'armée ukrainienne qui empêchent les
civils de fuir les combats c'est ce
qu'affirment plusieurs publications sur
les réseaux sociaux pour lui il s'agit
essentiellement de postes twitter
francophones et anglophones qui ont eu
beaucoup circuler ce week-end deux
exemples ce soit ce tweet d'abord en
langue anglaise qui évoque regarder la
junte de kiev qui l'a comparé au groupe
etat islamique en syrie et qui affirme
que le bouclier humain qu'elle utilise
le bouclier humain de l'otan et d'en
conclure que la propre à la propagande
coûte des vies d'abord ils ont détruit
le plombe le pont pardon nous dit cet
autre et puis désormais ils ne
permettent pas aux civils d'être évacués
sous la menace le tout sous la menace
d'une arme nous dit cet autre alors tous
ces comptes assure donc que ce ne sont
que deux exemples que l'armée
ukrainienne a empêché des civils de fuir
et que pour ce faire elle a fait
exploser ce pont en l'occurrence à
irbine à une vingtaine de kilomètres au
nord-ouest de kiev la capitale qui est
on le rappelle non pas kiev meilleur pin
sous le feu russe et vous remarquerez qu
à chaque fois c'est la même photo qui a
été utilisée pour appuyer les dires de
ses comptes justement cette photo le
cliché est authentique et il n'a pas été
des constats des considère
contextualiser facile effectivement la
décontextualisation c'est un peu le
propre de l'inde et informations c'est
très courant mais ce n'est pas le cas en
l'occurrence parce que il n'a pas été
décontextualisés mais il a été mal
utilisé ce cliché les explications c'est
que une recherche d'image inversée nous
donne l'origine en l'occurrence on est
sur le site des hippies l'agencé upi ce
cliché des crédits t yp il a été réalisé
par le photographe espagnol emilio
morenatti le 5 mars près d'un pont dire
pis que l'on retrouve grâce à la
géolocalisation c'est ici on voit donc
la rivière irvine le cours d'eau et le
pont en question la légende du cliché un
retour à cette photo elle nous dit quoi
elle nous dit bien que ce sont là des
ukrainiens qui tentent de fuir en
traversant cette rivière pin dans la
banlieue de kiev donc le contexte est
bien le bon l'exode actuelle des civils
haïr pin mais c'est la légende des
publications virale qui est fausse d'une
part parce que si l'armée ukrainienne a
bien détruit le pont il y a quelques
jours c'est par prévention pour ralentir
la progression hors us et éviter qu'elle
gagne la capitale et kiev c'est
d'ailleurs ce que confirme dans un de
ses reportages notre équipe sur place et
puis d'autre part les militaires
ukrainiens n'ont à ce moment là en aucun
cas empêcher les civils de fuir c'est ce
qu'on peut voir notamment dans ce
reportage de cyril payen mais aussi par
exemple dans la suite du reportage photo
d'emilio morenatti par exemple cette
photo en témoigne que les soldats
ukrainiens ont bien aidés en
l'occurrence a traversé sur des planches
de fortune ces civils qu'ils soient
hommes femmes ou enfants et on la voit
ici la légende justement que les soldats
d'ukrainiens ont aidé ces civils a
traversé la rivière pin dans les
banlieues de kiev est alors pour venir
en aide à ces civils des appels aux dons
pullulent sur les réseaux sociaux mais
attention aux arnaques oui depuis treize
jours de conflit maintenant c'est
surtout sur tik tok c'est l'application
des jeunes un finalement quelques elle
prolifère ces arnaques via défaut l'aïe
on va regarder une vidéo un exemple le
procédé est assez rodée vous avez ces
images sombres ces immeubles difficile à
localiser non identifiés des sirènes
aussi on entend en fond sonore et à cela
vous ajoutez parfois des coups de feu
des gémissements et vous avez finalement
la recette idéale pour celles de hier
assez convaincante et crédible qui joue
sur l'affect l'émotion la copas la
compassion pour susciter et soutenir et
surtout de l'argent et qui se mêle aussi
aux vraies images du front qui il faut
le dire existe bien sûr tik tok alors
comment les repérer bien c'est assez
difficile vous fait honnête mais il
n'est pas rare en fait que c'est que ces
scènes censées tournée est retourné en
direct se répète et donc par conséquent
il n'y a pas lieu de dire est qu'il faut
être par exemple très attentifs aux
bruits dans ces scènes et puis c'est le
cas ici par exemple ce sont très souvent
des images de nuit qui sont donc censés
être en live en direct mais lorsque vous
regardez leur par exemple 15h 17h à
paris donc 16h 17h ukrainienne et il
fait jour à cette époque de l'année en
ukraine le but de ces de ces faux live
c'est évidemment de soutirer l'argent
pourquoi parce que les créateurs de ces
contenus peuvent gagner eux mêmes de
l'argent via ce système de cadeaux de
tik tok c'est à dire en deux mots karine
utilisateurs qui va répondre à un appel
de dons va créer des pièces ces pièces
elles vont se transformer en cadeau et
ses cadeaux vont pouvoir être
transformée en vraie monnaie en monnaie
réelle pour le créateur de contenu et
plus le direct et virales plus le gain
peut être gros donc si vous voulez
donner en faveur de la population
ukrainienne et bien préférer les
plateformes officielle celle par exemple
du haut commissariat pour les réfugiés
des nations unies sion et donc attention
aux arnaques merci beaucoup anthony st
léger on peut retrouver votre chronique
et bien sûr sur notre site internet
www.francebillet.com nous on se retrouve
dans quelques instants paris direct
continue après une courte pause rester
avec nous